c'est un sujet que vous attendez tous on
parle beaucoup de vous pierre pierre
ménès pendant le quart d'heure sans
filtre sur élise lucet d'ailleurs y aura
un autre quart d'heure sans fil dans un
instant il se passe toujours quelque
chose dans le quart d'heure sans fil
vous aviez tenu des propos un peu durs
envers la journaliste de france 2 on va
revoir et après vous êtes excusé sur
twitter regarde parfois j'ai un peu
honte de faire le même métier qu'elle
parce que vous êtes jeu je la trouve
d'une agressivité incroyable j'ai déjà
eu l'occasion de le dire ici son achat
d'explications sur le foot est
lamentable la manière qu'elle a eue
d'invectivés le pape
j'ai trouvé ça très choquant le pipeau
c'est minable
mais voilà alors voila mon pierrot
vous êtes ensuite excusé sur twitter
j'ai été trop loin les dangers du direct
sur élise lucet je n'apprécie pas ses
méthodes mais elle ne me fait pas honte
non plus mea culpa
alors après sur twitter ça a été
déferlement tout le monde en a parlé
crise
alors il ya eu un faux compte de gérard
depardieu qui a fait réagir christine
boutin pierre ménès donnant des leçons
de journalisme à élise lucet c'est comme
christine boutin expliquant le kama
sutra rocco siffredi et christine boutin
est assez drôle à 10.7 on est sans doute
mieux le kama sutra taupiac ménès le
journalisme enfin a pas beaucoup
attendait là quand même
non merci il ya eu clairement qui a dit
rassurez-vous pierre ménès ce n'est pas
le cas il ya pierre ménès journaliste
d'investigation il ya quelqu'un qui a
mis ses frises voilà bon après voilà ils
ont mis des photos de julie ont peu à
peu sa faute elle fait la réponse à tout
cela on peut être journaliste et
déconner soit parce qu'on n'est pas
parce que même les journalistes qu'on
peut pas déconner et donc voilà il ya
aussi gras durs 4,8 et camille wesh à la
grossi doha
[Rires]
il ya guillaume tc qui est excellent qui
a croisé lise lui c'est vous guillaume
tc quel formidable regarder voilà qui
fait mais bon quand on veut qu'on a
c'est pas mal il est toujours bon alors
prière c'est vrai qu'il ya eu plein de
gens voilà qui nous sont tombées dessus
est ce que pensait que ça devait faire
autant de buzz cette petite sortie de
pierre ménès et pierre après je voudrais
avoir votre avis et vote des grâces vous
bat pierre ménès est très suivie sur les
réseaux sociaux et cette attaque
effectivement à élise lucet qui la
journaliste préférée des français
ouais bah là je trouve c'est à dire non
mais oh non mais moi je trouve que c'est
très bien en revanche que pierre s'il
trouve qu'il a il est allé trop loin
il n'a pas été assez nuancée qui soit
revenu sur ses propos je trouve qu'au
contraire c'est bien ça montre à quel
point le direct parfois empêche la
nuance et les punchlines empêche d'être
justement un petit peu pondérer non moi
je trouve qu'il a absolument raison de
revenir sur ses propos
okada n'a effectivement je trouve que
c'est une bonne chose qu'il soit revenu
sur ses propos moi quand j'ai regardé
l'émission quand j'étais étonné que
pierre retrouver élise lucet agressive
alors que c'est quand même sa marque de
fabrique à lui aussi il est franc et
dans les propos qu'il tient vis-à-vis
des gens parfois je lui ai dit tout à
l'heure on en a parlé jeudi c'est
marrant parce que toi aussi tu te gêne
pas parfois pour être un peu à bras
c'est ça qu'on aime chez eux je parle
frisquet oui mais c'est pour ça que de
voir ça chez quelqu'un d'autre bessat
étonnant après moi ce que j'ai trouvé
intéressant et le fait que son propos
soit isolée ça a un peu effacé le fait
que autour de la table y avait quand
même année qu'il y paraissait y avait
quand même des gens qui l'ont défendre
beaucoup dont j'aurais fait partie si
j'étais là parce que je trouve qu'elles
pratiquent un journalisme qui est
important car journalisme de service
public
effectivement son propos isolés pouvait
paraître un peu disproportionné mais
c'était bien qu'il y ait d'autres
alors que l'acteur tu l'avais nawel vous
n'aviez pas vu l'extrême et sur twitter
ça a été un déferlement ce week-end j'ai
plus qu'on ya eu plus de 16 mille tweets
on voit assez renom la cette affaire et
cette sortie de pierre ménès le faire de
la pub je trouvais ce que c'est c'est
légitime qu'il y ait autant de tweets
autant de buzz autour de ça ou pas artus
moi j'ai moi j'avoue je suis plus en
plus de malades avaient toutes un sens
mais pas déçu en a beaucoup qui ont ça
vraiment c'est une gratuité des fois les
fans fin mai il ya beaucoup de gens
aussi bien sur les vannes sur scène
agressif les gens aiment isolé sur
certaines choses je pense que c'est pas
vraiment leur en tout cas moi
alors j'aimerais par la ville avant le
déchaînement était complètement
disproportionnée par rapport aux propos
de pierre de pierre côté
voilà il n'a pas dit non plus des choses
horribles dit voilà qu elle était
agressive
non il n'a pas non plus dit chacun et
moi et moi bien pire moi je répondrai
pas présenter mes excuses en revanche
parce que dès qu'on donne un peu son
avis de façon un peu franches sans
utiliser pas le politiquement correct on
les attaquants sont obligés de faire
machine arrière présente mes excuses
parce que je pense que j'ai merdé
quand j'ai traité gains et d'autres
tourte j'ai jamais plus jamais mais non
parce que tu des fois tu te laisse
emporter c'est bien qu'ils passent comme
ça c'est la vie oui dans le direct tout
était dans le flou et c'est bien de
présenter ses excuses par rapport à
twitter c'est que justement c'est un bon
moyen de coop pour pour ce qu'il a fait
il a dit deux choses qui étaient un peu
loin c'est du direct et directe direct
fait des excuses c'est très bien répond
t c'est bien le faire ils ont tous voila
et quand je tire t bref les joueurs
croient dit j'ai des rendez vous chez le
psy a moins comme une chose qui m'a
frappé c'est que la principale
intéressée a pas réagi or elle a été au
courant et honnêtement elle n'a pas fait
on n'a pas fait les meilleurs se sont
occupés de moi oui j'ai raconté une
anecdote sympa sur elle quand elle m'a
laissé copie en plus ça ils n'ont pas
repris alors on va voir le sondage
regardez sur pire mais les propos de
pierre ménès mérite est il autant de
doses non à 58% à 42 kamga 42% temps
qu'ils pensaient alors pierre ce que
vous avez quelque chose à dire ce soir
ben je regrette d'avoir dit on parce
qu'en fait c'est faux elle me fait pas
honte quand est ce qui concerne de faire
le même qui est le même mais teckel
effectivement je ne fais pas le même
métier qu'elle on me reproche de faire
de la pub
je suis désolé je fais ce que je veux je
n'ai plus de carte de presse depuis que
je suis à canal+ parce que jusqu'à eux
j'ai été payé en factures et quand tu es
en facture pas avoir de carte de presse
donc j'ai parfaitement le droit de faire
de la suite voilà je regrette juste
d'avoir dit honte je me suis excusé
parce que j'aille en corse avait
toujours fait longtemps que j'ai
toujours fait dans ma carrière quand
j'ai été trop loin
je me suis toujours excuser
ça peut arriver non plus 50 fois voilà
je regrette le monde et voilà alors moi
je voudrais juste dire un truc sur pérot
pierrot je voudrais dire que pierrot
c'est un vrai gentil et dans la vie et
c'est souvent les vrais gentils comme ma
fille je parie firme
voilà c'est vrai je voudrais très gentil
et qui dit ce qu'ils pensaient les aeros
et un amour de mecs dans la vie et c'est
pour ça que je les aime et c'est pour ça
qu'il auto que c'est pas parce que ici
il n'y a que des vrais gentils en fait
dans la vie y voit la même même si le
werder 1 voilà dans le joli
[Applaudissements]